after this video you will know what the
variance is
how to calculate it why there are two
different formulas and what a difference
is to the standard deviation and let's
get started right now
what is the variance the variance is a
measure that indicates how much your
data scatters around the mean so the
variance has something to do with the
dispersion of your data here is a simple
example
let's say you measure the height of a
small group of people
the variance tells us how much our data
scatters around the mean so first we
need to calculate the mean
the mean is easily obtained by summing
the heights of the individuals
and dividing them by the number of
individuals
let's say the result is a mean value of
155
centimeters now we want to know how much
the data scatters around the mean value
in order to figure this out we look at
the difference of each person to the
mean value so we look at the first
person who deviates 18 centimeters from
the mean the second person deviates
minus 8 centimeters from the mean the
third minus 15 centimeters the fourth
eight centimeters
the fifth minus nine centimeters and
finally the sixth person deviates six
centimeters from the mean but we want to
get a positive value every time
no matter if the person is bigger or
smaller than the mean
therefore we square the difference for
the first person we have 18 times 18
which is
324
for the second person we have minus 8
times -8 which is 64.
and for the third person we have
225 and so on and so forth now you are
not interested in the deviation of each
individual person from the mean value
but you want to know how big the spread
is on average
therefore we sum up all values that is
794 and divide this value by the number
of participants in our case the number
is six
this is then 132.33
it is important to know that by squaring
the unit is no longer centimeters but
centimeters squared
so now we have calculated the average
squared deviation from the mean and
exactly that is the variance but slowly
again how is the formula for the
variance now exactly you can calculate
the variance with the following formula
n is the number of persons in our case
it is 6
x i is the size of the individual
persons and x dash is the mean value of
all people
so the variance is the sum of squared
differences
divided by the number of values
for example this means that we calculate
the size of the first person minus the
mean and square it
the size of the second person minus the
mean and square it and so on until we
arrive at last person
we then divide this by the number of
people in our case six the result is
then 132.30
centimeters squared so each person has
some squared deviation from the mean of
course but on average the square
deviation from the mean is
133.3
centimeters squared
at this point you can already see why
the variance is a little bit harder to
interpret than the standard deviation
this brings us to the next point what is
the difference between the variance and
the standard deviation now
as you already know the variance is the
squared average distance from the mean
the standard deviation is the average
distance from the mean without the
square
so we have one at the same formula the
only difference is that in order to
calculate the standard deviation the
root is taken and for the variance it is
not
if we put it another way the variance is
the squared standard deviation
and the standard deviation is the root
of the variance by taking the root of
the standard deviation it is easier to
interpret the standard deviation than
the variance
by taking the root the standard
deviation always has the same unit as
the original data
in our example it is centimeters
the variance is in centimeters squared
for this reason it is advisable to
always use the standard deviation to
describe your data
as it is easier to interpret
now you might notice one thing i always
talk about the mean deviation from the
mean value in the standard deviation
but for the mean deviation i would
actually just add up all the deviations
and divide them by the number of
participants just like you calculate a
mean value you're absolutely right with
that
but there are different mean values
in the case of the standard deviation
it's not the arithmetic mean that is
used but a quadratic mean if the
arithmetic mean would be used the result
would be zero every time
so far so good but now there's one more
thing to consider namely there are two
slightly different formulas for the
variance
the difference between the equations is
that one is divided by n
and one is divided by n minus one but
why why are there two different formulas
usually you want to know the variance of
the population for example you want to
know the variance of the hate of all
german professional soccer players
now if you had the hate of all german
professional soccer players
you would take this equation with 1
divided by n
usually it is not possible to serve the
whole population so you take a sample
and want to estimate the variance of the
population with this sample
in this case you use this formula
therefore whenever you have all the data
and you want to calculate the variance
for just this data you use
1 divided by n
if you only have one sample and you want
to estimate the variance for the whole
population you use n minus 1.
if you created a questionnaire and your
survey did not cover the whole
population
you always use the formula on the right
side
likewise if you have conducted a
clinical study then you also use the
formula on the right to estimate the
variance of the population
by default the common statistics
software solutions for example like tab
calculate the variance using the formula
on the right side if you want to
calculate the variance you can easily do
this online with data tab just visit
datadeb.net
copy your data into this table and then
you select the variable you want to
analyze further you simply click on the
variance and you will get the variance
output in a very uncomplicated way
so i hope you liked the video and see
you next time bye bye
you